PAUL FREEDMAN: Today
we're going to talk about the
transformation of the
Roman Empire.
And I use the somewhat neutral
and undramatic word
"transformation." It can be
"fall of the Roman Empire,"
"collapse of the Roman
Empire..." It's clear that
we're talking about the fall
of the Western Empire.
Next week we'll talk
about the survival
of the Eastern Empire.
From 410 to 480, the Western
Roman Empire disintegrated.
It was dismembered by barbarian
groups who were,
except for the Huns, not
really very barbarian.
That is, they were not intent
on mayhem and destruction.
All they really wanted to do was
to be part of the Empire,
to share in its wealth and
accomplishments, rather than
to destroy it.
Nevertheless, 476 is the
conventional date for the end
of the Western Empire, because
in that year, a barbarian
chieftain deposed
a Roman emperor.
Nothing very new about this
for the fifth century.
What was new is that this
chieftain, whose name is
spelled all sorts of different
ways, but in
Wickham, it's Odovacer.
Sometimes he's known as Odacaer,
Odovacar, Odovacer.
We aren't even sure
what so-called
tribe he belonged to.
A barbarian general deposed
the child emperor Romulus
Augustulus, who by an
interesting coincidence, has
the names of both the founder
of the city of Rome and the
founder of the Roman Empire.
The "-us" on the
end is little.
It's a diminutive.
So a man with this grandiose
name, a child, deposed in 476.
And instead of imposing another
emperor, Odovacer
simply wrote to Constantinople
and said, "We're going to be
loyal to you.
We will recognize you as the
sole emperor." Constantinople,
however, was far away.
And while of symbolic
significance, this pledge of
loyalty by Odovacer had no
practical significance.
For all intents and purposes,
the Western Empire had, in
476, become a collection
of barbarian kingdoms.
A kingdom is smaller
than an empire.
We use the term empire to mean
a multi-national, very large
state ruled from one center,
but consisting of many
different kinds of pieces.
Kings, and the term and title
"king", is of German origin.
Kings are very powerful, but
over a more limited territory.
So there was a king
of Italy now.
There would be a king of the
Franks, or Francia, the former
Roman Gaul.
There would be a king
of the Lombards
later in northern Italy.
A king of the Visigoths, first
in southern France and Spain.
And we'll go over who
is where at the
beginning of next class.
For now, we're going to talk
about this collapse and its
consequences.
And we're going to
orient ourselves
around three big questions.
One--
why did the west fall apart?
And as a corollary to that
question, was this because of
the external pressure of
invasions or the internal
problems of institutional
decline.
Did it fall of its own
accord or was it
pushed, in other words?
Question number two.
Or big question number two.
Who were these barbarians?
And how Romanised or how
different from Rome were they?
And that's what we're going to
talk about more on Wednesday,
next class.
And three, does this
transformation mark a gradual
shift to another civilization,
or is it the cataclysmic end
of the prevailing form of
civilization, ushering in a
prolonged period of what used
to be called The Dark Ages?
The Dark Ages--
roughly the sixth to
eleventh century.
This is a term we don't
like to use.
It implies a value judgment
that is not only not
necessarily accurate, but also
expresses a certain kind of
point of view of what are good
periods in history and what
are bad periods in history.
But I'd like to just probe this
third question first.
That is, how severe a
catastrophe was this?
So is it the end of
civilization, a la Planet of
the Apes or Blade Runner, or
any of those apocalyptic
images we have?
Or is it merely a shift in
power and the survival of
Roman institutions such as the
Church, while Roman political
infrastructure--
the emperor, the consoles, the
pratorian prefects, and so
forth-- while that collapses?
A medieval historian named Roger
Collins in a book called
The Early Middle Ages writes,
"The fall of the Roman Empire
in the west was not the
disappearance of a
civilization.
It was merely the breakdown of
a governmental apparatus that
could no longer be sustained."
The key word here is "merely."
The destruction of the Roman
political apparatus may simply
mean that the Roman state ceased
to function, but that
everything else continued.
But really, the question is,
could everything else continue
in the absence of a state and
of a political order?
The destruction of the political
order also means,
after all, the destruction
of the military system.
When we opened this class, we
talked about a civilization
built on such things as the
rule of law and the
maintenance of peace.
These are no longer possible
if there is no military
governmental structure.
As we'll say a little later, to
some extent people didn't
know that it was the end.
Because for a while, things
seemed to go on as before.
People were speaking Latin, they
were living in cities,
the cities were much less
populated, but nevertheless,
they were still there; there
were still rich people; there
were still poor people.
In retrospect, though,
we can see that
things really did change.
How much they changed is the
subject of a lot of historical
controversy.
The world of the late Roman
historians is divided, roughly
speaking, between catastrophists
and
continuists.
As you may guess, the
catastrophists think the fall
of the Roman Empire--, whether
we date it 476 or there's some
reasons to date it, really,
550 for reasons we'll
learn in next week.
Between 450 and 550, a
catastrophe happened.
A civilization was wiped out.
And really, if not literally a
Dark Ages, a more primitive,
more war-like, more illiterate,
and more rural
period was ushered in.
The disappearance of ancient
texts, things that the Romans
knew from that lost Hortensius
dialogue of Cicero that
Augustine was so fond of, to
many other kinds of works that
had been known to the
Roman world, right?
I can't remember exactly how
many plays Aeschylus wrote,
but it's something
on the order of
60, and we have three.
So the disappearance of text.
The end of literacy, except for
a very small portion of
the Christian clergy.
A more primitive architecture.
The end of grand civic projects
like aqueducts,
coliseums, theaters, baths.
A more isolated society without
these urban centers.
A diminished population spread
across the countryside, mostly
engaged in subsistence.
Hence, the, if not end
of trade, the radical
diminution of trade.
The continuists, people like
Collins whom I just quoted,
see the political changes as
dramatic all right, but as
essentially surface phenomena
based partly on archaeology
and partly on a more sympathetic
understanding of
Christian practices.
In other words, they don't think
that the proliferation
of churches, saints, cults,
is necessarily a sign of a
primitiveness.
So based on both archaeology
and an understanding of
Christianity, these continuists
point to the
survival of trade, the role of
bishops and other church
officials, as replacing
the Roman governors.
The Roman political order may
have collapsed in terms of
staffing by lay people and
military people, but the
bishops were now the
rulers of the city.
The bishops would now do things
like ensure the food
supply, rally the local
population against barbarian
invasions, educate
the populace.
And the barbarian kings
themselves try, with some
success, to perpetuate
the Roman order.
They collect taxes,
for example--
that may or may not
be a good thing.
They engage in some kind of
public works, some kind of
maintenance of order.
The civilization of the sixth
and seventh centuries in what
comes to be considered Western
Europe, rather than the
Western Roman Empire, is not
radically more barbarized or
primitive than the late
Roman Empire.
Thus, the continuists.
My own position, but I don't
hold to it dogmatically, is
that of a moderate
catastrophist. I think
something really happened; I
think it's pretty radical; and
it didn't happen all
at once, however.
476 is not the year
of collapse.
It is a process.
I'm fascinated by the degree to
which people were and were
not aware of the cataclysm,
but I
believe there is a cataclysm.
Wickham, the author of this book
that we're starting now
The Inheritance of Rome, Chris
Wickham, straddles the fence,
as you've seen.
His chapter that you were to
read for today is entitled,
"Crisis and Continuity: 400 to
550." I would never use a
chapter title like that,
because it's really
frustrating.
Which is it, dude?
He's the leading medieval
historian in the English -
speaking world.
He is Chichele Professor
at All Souls, Oxford.
And if that doesn't sound
impressive, well, it takes a
lot to impress you.
He's a very great historian,
but I don't like
that chapter title.
As I said, I would emphasize
crisis or change cataclysm.
Well, let's ask what happened,
beginning with the gradual
involvement of the barbarians
in the military and their
entrance into the empire.
We're using the term
"barbarians", which goes back
to the Greek term applied
to outsiders.
People outside but
threatening.
The Greeks defined barbarians
as uncivilized by reason of
their speech, which sounded to
them incoherent, and by reason
of the fact that
they're nomads.
People who lead settled lives
don't trust nomads.
Nomads almost extinct in our
world, once dominated many
geographical regions and were
frightening, because they
moved to around to people who
liked order and familiarity.
They didn't live in cities,
whether they
were nomadic or not.
Barbarians were illiterate.
This is the Greek idea
of barbarians.
In the case of Rome, there is
no single definition of
barbarian society.
We can say that Rome was
overthrown by a war-like, but
not very fierce, group
of enemies.
And I use enemies in
a very mild sense.
The Romans perceived them as
enemies; the barbarians
perceived Rome as simply
a nicer place to live.
But there is no Mongol horde
kind of event here.
They're not that frightening.
The Romans had known
them for centuries.
Most of them were even
Christians Heretical
Christians, OK.
They're Arians, A-R-I-A-N-S, I
remind you, but they're not
unfamiliar, again, even
in their religion.
They've been at the borders of
the Roman empire forever.
Like most empires, Rome was at
the one hand, very aggressive,
and on the other hand thought
of itself is peace-loving.
It maintained the Danube-Rhine
frontier as a kind of natural
frontier, every so often
crossing those rivers to
punish German tribes who
were probing the
frontiers of the empire.
But generally speaking, the
Romans were not interested in
what they perceived, somewhat
inaccurately, as endless
forests inhabited by
primitive people.
The continuists argue, with some
justice, that between 250
and 600 what changed was not
that primitive warriors
conquered a civilized state,
in the way that say, the
Mongols conquered China in the
thirteenth century, but that
the ancient world became
the medieval world.
That is, an urban culture
became more rural.
A Latin culture became
amalgamated to a German one.
Pagan society became
Christian.
Having said this, it's
nevertheless true that the
most dramatic event to the fifth
century is that people
who had been outside the
empire were now in it.
If we ask why the Western Empire
collapsed, the simple,
most immediate answer is it
was taken over by German
confederations, tribes.
They came not so much as
conquerors as military
recruits, or as allies,
or as refugees.
So rather than as guys with
knives in their teeth hacking
and slashing and burning, they
came as pathetic refugees,
maybe doing some hacking,
slashing, and burning; as
military recruits; and
as military allies.
Again, not without a certain
amount of H. S. B.: hacking
and slashing and burning.
But not a cataclysmic amount.
They admired Rome.
They wanted to continue
its institutions.
They regarded Rome as a
rich and as civilized.
The last thing they wanted was
to still live in little huts
in the forest.
They were not the bringers
of a revolution.
They were not even that
numerous, amounting to some
tens of thousands.
Nevertheless, they ended Roman
government, accelerated the
changes we've already
described towards
depopulation, decentralization,
ruralization--
a less cultivated, less
literate, less Mediterranean-
centered society.
So I want to begin the
description of this process by
the changes in the Roman army.
We saw that Diocletian, around
300 AD, militarizes Roman
government, pays for the,
perhaps, doubling of the
military presence of the
Roman army by changing
the taxation system.
So the twin pillars of the
empire in the fourth century
are army and taxation, the
latter requiring a civilian
governmental apparatus.
The army was a problem
in terms of the
recruiting of soldiers.
This may have to do with the
population; it may have to do
with the unattractive nature
of military life, but
nevertheless there was already,
in the fourth
century, a tendency to get the
more familiar barbarians into
the army as Roman soldiers.
Because they were available,
they were near the frontiers--
this may seem odd.
Why hire your potential
enemy to be soldiers?
But there's a lot
of precedent.
Very often, empires don't really
want to supply their
own manpower.
And the people who are the best
soldiers are also the
people who may, in the future,
be most threatening.
I don't want to pursue this
simile, but the Afghan
Mujahidiee were trained by
Americans, because at one time
they were opposed to the
Russian occupation of
Afghanistan.
As it happened, in retrospect,
that had some bad
consequences.
But at the time, it seemed
like a good idea.
So in the 370s a group called
the Visigoths asks to be
admitted to the Roman Empire
as an allied army.
In other words, the whole group
will be federated with
the Romans.
And federati is the term given
for barbarian troops serving
under the Roman Empire.
Why were they on the move?
These are not really
nomadic people.
They don't live in yurts or
travel across Central Asia.
They tend to be settled
in villages.
They have dairy cattle rather
than have some kind of nomadic
sheep, or something like.
They're pretty settled.
Nevertheless, in 378, they
were on the move.
And we don't know why.
Some enemy pushing them
across the Danube
into what's now Romania?
It may be the weakness
of the Empire.
They may have seen that the
empire was not so strong and
made a proposition, kind
of like a takeover.
You don't seem to be doing so
well in your stock or your
finances, so we're going to
infuse some capital into you,
i.e., our soldiers.
They also may have
been hungry.
Certainly, once they crossed the
frontier, the Romans were
rather inept in feeding them,
in supplying them, and the
Visigoths rebelled.
Thus far, nothing
incredibly new.
What really was new was that the
emperor came with an army
to suppress them.
And rather to his surprise and
everybody else's, the emperor
Valens was defeated at the
battle of Adrianopole.
Defeated by the barbarians.
Yeah.
STUDENT: So, being involved in
this federati, what did they
get from the Roman Empire?
Did they agree to fight for them
and then they'd get land?
PROFESSOR: They
agreed to fight for them and
they got a combination of land,
or supposed to get land
or territory, and some
kind of maintenance
in kind and or money.
The question was about what the
Visigoths, as federati,
got out of this deal.
Or were supposed to get.
The defeat at Valens was not
immediately cataclysmic,
because, even though he was
killed at this battle, even
though it sent shock waves
throughout the empire, in
fact, it would not be this area
that succumbed to the
barbarians--, the East. Romania,
or the Balkans would
be part of the Eastern Empire.
And indeed, both Adrianople the
city, and Constantinople,
the even greater city, would
withstand Visigothic attempts
to take them.
In 382, the Visigoths were
officially recognized, and
they were allowed to settle in
the Balkans as federati.
And in fact, they were
reasonably useful troops to
the Roman Empire in
the 380s and 390s.
What this does show,
however, is the
barbarization of the army.
And another aspect of that is
that the army tended to be
commanded now more and more
by barbarian generals.
These barbarian generals, at
the top, bore the title
magister militum--
master of the soldiers.
So I'm using the term "general"
as an anachronistic
one, since that's what
we're familiar with.
These magistri were powerful
leaders, charismatic leaders,
of German or other tribal
groups, who then ruled in the
name of, or behind the throne
of the emperor.
They couldn't be emperors
themselves, at least in these
years, it was impossible to
envisage a barbarian emperor.
But they held more power
than the emperors.
Two of these generals, war
leaders, magistri, Stilicho
and Alaric.
Stilicho was a Vandal Alaric
was a Visigoth.
Alaric wanted territory, food,
treasure from Rome.
The Visigoths were moving from
the Balkans into Greece,
eventually into Italy.
Stilicho played a kind of game
with Alaric, trying to keep
him in check in the name of the
Western emperor, but also
negotiating with him.
The emperors moved from Milan
in the north to Ravenna, a
little bit to the east. Ravenna,
then, was in the
marshes and impossible for
a barbarian army to take.
This is the last capital of
the Western Roman Empire.
Kind of romantic and mysterious,
but strange as a
place to end up.
These are the Visigoths then,
who are on the move in the
390s and the 400s.
Eventually, Stilicho would be
executed by the Roman emperor
of the West and Alaric
would invade and
plunder Rome in 410.
It was the Visigoths who
engineered the so-called Sack
of Rome that so shocked
Augustine and his
contemporaries.
Where, you might be asking
in all of this,
was the Roman army?
Alaric was wandering around the
Balkans and Italy for two
decades before he sacked Rome.
The army, which had consumed
so much of the resources of
the Roman Empire, is curiously
absent in the history of the
fifth century.
This is not the Eastern
Front in World War II.
This is something altogether
different: the collapse of an
empire that expended
huge amounts of
treasure on its army.
Its army seems to be invisible
and supports, to some extent,
or that fact supports to some
extent--, the argument that
the Roman Empire collapsed of
its own internal disorders,
since we don't see it losing
pitched battles to outside
barbarians.
Or maybe the army doesn't
disappear, it becomes
indistinguishable from
the invaders.
The army is the invaders.
Creepier.
Now within this, there are
some real barbarians--
the Huns.
The Huns are kind of nomadic.
OK, they didn't actually cook
their meat by holding it
between their thigh and the
horse hide, and the sweat and
heat of the horse heated
up the meat.
This is a widespread myth
of nomadic peoples.
The Chinese say this about
the Mongols, the
Romans about Huns.
But they were pretty mean.
They were interested
in the Roman
Empire mostly for plunder.
And they didn't care if that
destroyed the economic base,
because they weren't thinking
in such terms. And indeed,
they may have frightened the
rather nice German tribes that
stood between them and
the Roman Empire.
In the 450s the Huns were
united under the
leadership of Attila.
And Attila certainly threatened
the Eastern Empire
first, but the Eastern emperor
defeated the Huns,
discontinued tribute to them,
and in a pattern that we'll
see repeated again and again,
the Huns decided that
Constantinople was too tough.
That the Eastern Empire as a
whole, access to which was
more or less controlled
by Constantinople,
was too well guarded.
And they turned to
the west instead.
Not as rich maybe, but
much easier pickings.
They show up in Gaul in 450.
They were defeated
by an army of
Visigoths allied with Romans.
They then went to Italy.
They went into the heart of the
Empire, sacked cities in
the northeast of Italy,
and there's no army.
The emperor is holed
up in Ravenna.
basically shuts the door, gets
under the bed, and waits for
it to go away.
The one power of Italy willing
to try to deal with Attila is
the Bishop of Rome, whom we
haven't heard of yet, but
we're going to be hearing
about him a lot.
And indeed, in the course that
follows this, even more.
The Bishop of Rome-- the pope.
Pope Leo I, along with two
senators from the Roman
senate, goes up to northern
Italy to remonstrate with
Attila, to visit the leader of
this barbarian tribe in 453 to
try to get him to stop
plundering Italy.
Whether they were successful
or not doesn't much matter,
because Attila died shortly
thereafter of a brain
hemorrhage.
And with his charismatic
leadership, the Huns came to
an end as a military force.
That is, with the end of his
leadership, the Huns no longer
had as imposing a military
force and quickly
disintegrated.
What's significant is that it's
the pope who is taking
over what we would think of
as the Roman imperial
responsibilities.
And this will be a pattern, not
only in the assertion of
papal power, but in the way in
which the Church starts to
take over many of the roles
abandoned by the empire.
After this, the barbarian
generals, in
effect, take charge.
The Huns are defeated, but
the other groups now
pour into the empire.
The Vandals have taken over
North Africa by this time, by
430, cutting off the grain
supply to Rome.
They are unusual among the
barbarian groups in that they
have a navy.
They know how to use boats, and
indeed, they plunder the
city of Rome in 455 in a sack
that might have been worse
than that of 410.
By 470, the Visigoths control
southern Gaul, what's now
southern France; a group called
the Suevi are in Spain;
the Vandals in North Africa; a
group called the Ostrogoths in
what's now Hungary; the Angles
and the Saxons in Britain.
All that effectively remained
of the Western empire when
Odovacer overthrew Romulus
Augustulus was Italy.
And in 476, that's it.
A little coda, however.
In 493, the Eastern emperor in
Constantinople convinced the
Ostrogoths to get out of
Hungary, stop threatening the
Eastern Empire, and take
Italy from Odovacer.
Once again, the Eastern Empire
is capable of deflecting
barbarians into the west,
because they're too strong.
So in 493, our friend Odovacer
was overthrown by the
Ostrogoths and their
leader Theoderic.
So what's the impact
of all of this?
On the ground, if you were
looking around in 480s 490s,
you would see a kind
of accommodation.
The Roman elite accommodated
themselves to, compromised
with, negotiated with,
their new rulers.
So, for example, a member of a
very wealthy Roman family, a
man named Sidonius Apollinaris
in southern France, was a
bishop and a great landowner.
And we have a lot of letters of
his that tell us about his
negotiations with the Visigothic
king Euric.
He found the Vsigoths uncouth,
hard to deal with, not
knowledgeable of the Latin
classics, but not very
frightening, either.
Not particularly formidable.
So accommodation,
improvisation.
We have a saint's life that
is a biography of a
saint, a man named--
I'm sorry that I'm writing on
the board so much today.
Usually, as you know, I'm a
little more in control.
But these are great names.
And some of them are good cats
names or dog names, too.
Severinus of Noricum.
You know, "Stop scratching the
furniture, Severinus." That
kind of thing.
Severinus of Noricum.
A saint in what's now, more
or less, Austria.
His life tells us that he
learned of the end of the
Roman Empire this way:
"At the time when the Roman
Empire was still in existence,
the soldiers of many towns were
supported by public money
to guard the frontier.
When this arrangement ceased,
the military formations were
dissolved, and the frontier
vanished.
The garrison of Passau, which
is still a town in modern
Bavaria, the garrison
of Passau,
however, still held out.
Some of the men had gone to
Italy to fetch for their
comrades their last payment."
This resembles a corporation--
somebody, actually, was telling
me yesterday they
worked for Eastern Airlines,
a company that went out of
business in 1990.
And so sudden was the collapse
of Eastern, even though it had
been predicted, that she was a
flight attendant and had to
get on another airline
in order to get home.
She lived in New York; she was
in Florida; Eastern ceased to
exist. So these soldiers are
in the same position.
They want to get their
last paycheck.
They were never heard
from again.
Nobody knew that they, in
fact, were killed by
barbarians on the way.
"One day, when Saint Severinus
was reading in his cell, he
suddenly closed the book
and began to sigh.
The river, he said, was now
red with human blood.
At that moment the news arrived
that the soldiers had
been washed ashore
by the current."
Interestingly enough, he
doesn't just stay in
his cell and pray.
He starts to organize
this society.
He is active, although some of
it involves some miracles, in
poor relief.
He deals with the local
barbarian king, the king of
the Alamanni, remonstrates
with him.
He helps in diverting
Odovacer into Italy.
Again, like Pope Leo, we have a
member of the church, and in
this case somebody that you
would think was a recluse,
indeed had been living like a
recluse, nevertheless taking
over the responsibilities for a
population abandoned by its
civilian government.
That is then one of the forms
of accommodation.
Another aspect of this era,
however, is decline.
The urban population declines.
The society and economy
experienced what Wickham
euphemistically calls,
"a radical material
simplification." The term
he uses, I believe,
on page 95 and 105.
"Radical material
simplification" means that
your standard of living
plummets.
Cruder ceramics.
Instead of that nice, north
African red slip ware, you've
got mud that you
baked at home.
Fewer imports, no pepper.
More homemade, crude
building materials.
Fewer luxury goods.
The Vandal control of North
Africa meant the end of the
Roman wheat supply.
The countryside of Rome had not
grown enough wheat to feed
the city since 200 BC.
So for 600 years, minimum, Rome
was dependent on other
sources of supply.
Southern Italy, Sicily,
North Africa.
The moment the Vandals cut the
supply, the city could no
longer support its massive
population,
could not feed everybody.
When you multiply this
phenomenon, it's not a
surprise that the city's decline
in population, and
that the society becomes more
rural, more agricultural, more
subsistent
And here's where I think Collins
is naive to speak of
merely a political decline.
Without a government and
military structure, trade
could not take place on the
scale it had before.
And without that trade, cities
could not survive.
There is no denying a decline
in culture, economy, and
population.
Let's just look at Roman
population figures, based on
things like pork supply figures,
public-- well, I
mean, nobody took a
census in Rome.
We don't really know exactly how
many people lived there at
any given time.
But historians and
archaeologists looking at
things like food supply, public
welfare payments, water
delivery figures, for aqueducts,
and the abandonment
of houses and of
building sites.
Probably in 5 BC, the Roman
population was 800,000.
That would be a fairly
conservative estimate.
Maybe as much as a million,
but definitely 800,000.
5 BC.
Yeah?
STUDENT: This is just
the city of Rome?
PROFESSOR:
Just the city of Rome.
Yes, just the city of Rome.
At the time of Constantine,
sort of where we begin the
course, more or less, in the
early fourth century, the
population had declined
probably to 600,000.
After the sack of Rome in 419,
probably 300,000 to 500,000.
Obviously, these are
very rough figures.
But after the sack of Rome,
more than half of the
population that had existed
in 5 BC is gone.
With the end of grain shipments
from North Africa,
we don't really know
immediately.
We can estimate that by 590,
there could not have been more
than 150,000 people in Rome.
This is after not only the
Vandals, but after a
catastrophic war in Italy
launched by the Byzantine
Emperor Justinian, who we'll
be talking about next week.
In 800, on Christmas Day,
Charlemagne was crowned in
Saint Peter's in Rome as Roman
Emperor by the pope, an act
whose implications we will
be exploring towards
the end of the class.
On that day, Rome must've had
maximum, maximum, most
optimistic estimate,
30,000 people.
This does not necessarily mean
that they were primitive, but
they were living in the
Coliseum, for example.
People built houses in there.
They used the walls of the
Coliseum as a fort.
There is a certain Planet of
the Apes quality, in fact.
Rome, still to this day, is
filled with picturesque ruins,
even though it is a city
of two and a half,
three million people.
As I said, people were
not necessarily
aware of this change.
For example, lots of churches
were built at this time, and
some of them have mosaic
pavements that have mottos
about the grandeur of the Roman
name, and the usual
classical kind of mottos.
But then again, people often
aren't aware of what's
happening to them.
I mean, what if somebody in the
future points to the fact
that New Haven, in 1920, had far
more people living in it
than it does now?
New Haven lost a third
of its population
between 1950 and 1980.
What if some future historian
is scandalized at the fact
that in order to get into Yale a
hundred years ago you had to
know Greek and Latin.
If you look at what those
gentlemen C Students had to
study, or were responsible
for, in say, 1925, it's
extraordinary.
It's not very impressive in the
sciences, but the decline
of the humanities, if by decline
we mean things like
knowledge of classical
literature, is stunning.
Somebody may decide in a few
hundred years that the Dark
Ages began in about 1950.
And that those pathetic people
in, say, 2011, impressed with
their little technological
toys,
nonetheless didn't know
anything.
Now I don't actually
believe that.
There are some people who do.
There's a philosopher at Notre
Dame named Alasdair MacIntyre
who really believes that the
Dark Ages began a long time
ago, and we simply don't know.
We simply refuse to
recognize this.
I was impressed by an obituary
for a man named Patrick Leigh
Fermor, who died at the age
of 96 earlier this year.
This is the last of the great
British characters of the
twentieth century.
He not only was classically
trained, wrote a lot about
Greece, lived in Greece, he, in
World World II, disguised
himself as a Greek shepherd in
Crete, engineered the capture
of a German general, and the
delivery of that general after
three weeks of hiking through
the mountains of Crete to a
British destroyer.
It's in a movie called Ill Met
By Moonlight, if you ever want
to check this out.
Not a great movie, but--
Patrick Leigh Fermor also
wrote two books out of a
projected three about walking
from Holland to Constantinople
or, Baghdad actually, I
think, in the 1930s.
But the obituary describes a
conversation he had with this
German general, whom he is
trying to get across Crete.
And the general at one point,
over some fire in the
wilderness, quotes a line from
Horace, the Roman poet, that
then Patrick Leigh Fermor
finishes is for him, and
indeed, quotes the
next two stanzas.
Well, that world is over.
That world is over.
I don't pretend to be part
of that world, either.
And that's a world that would
have existed in the time of
Horace, or the years after
Horace, who lives at the time
of Augustus.
This would have existed in 300 A
D. It would have existed, at
least, in a few monasteries
in 800 AD.
It would have flourished in the
Britain of the eighteenth
and nineteenth and early
twentieth centuries.
So again, I don't think that
civilization came to an end.
What came to an end was a
civilization, a certain kind
of society.
It has some heirs, however,
like all dead entities.
There are four heirs to
the Roman Empire.
One is the Byzantine Empire,
the Eastern Roman Empire,
which calls itself
the Roman Empire.
It doesn't call itself the
Eastern, doesn't call itself
the Byzantine, it calls itself
the Roman Empire, even though
it does so in Greek.
The second heir are the
barbarian kings.
We'll be talking about
them on Wednesday.
They are attempting to prop up
the remnants of Roman culture,
civilization, and material
society.
The third heir in some ways, is
Islam, which we meet in the
seventh century, the century
of its invention.
And the fourth heir
is the Church.
Even though the Church grew up
in opposition to the Roman
Empire, it will preserve Latin,
cities, learning,
classical civilization.
OK.
So barbarians on Wednesday.